like i know a lot of people who have  built walls around  certain you know  certain pains in their life and by dint  of that are able to kind of safely  navigate through their life but they  want to stay in that lane and if you say  listen  you're missing a huge growth or a  certain level of enriching life  experience by ignoring that you're  asking people to confront  painful past emotions or to look  objectively at stuff that they've kind  of worked hard to build walls around  right so that prospect of deconstructing  those walls and really grappling  with some past trauma or some something  that occurred or whatever requires a a  certain level of of courage and i think  it is frightening for a lot of people  you should look at it and if you work  through it like your life is going to  open up in ways you can't possibly  imagine